Greg's leftovers oh I hope these are
good I hope these are good it's
leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading them so if they
suck we'll marinate Joe Mackey in olive
oil and toss him into our Woodfired
oven all right this week on CNN van
Jones advised President Biden to stay
hidden during the campaign to which Joe
responded wow a van that talks just like
that car in Night
[Laughter]
Rider during a speech this week the
president implied that Terry mccauliff
was the rightful governor of Virginia
but he later clarified his remarks
saying glurg morph bloga
F
really yes I love you there you
go the publisher of sport Sports
Illustrated announced they've laid off
most of the staff the worst part they
were all notified on their football
phones remember those they come with a
subscription for people born before
1980 a new study finds that the trick to
a great vacation for married people is
to travel without your
partner translation the trick to a great
vacation is not to be married
scientists have discovered skeletons
with the oldest DNA evidence of syphilis
in
Brazil wow how did Heff get to
Brazil funny cuz he's
dead while appearing on a podcast AOC
claimed Trump voters are insecure about
their masculinity well no wonder I'm
voting for Biden said Randy we
Garden
still looks like Gary
chandling this week a Delta flight was
grounded after one of the front wheels
fell off on the upside the wheel was
booked on the next flight to Fort
Lauderdale with two free drink
tickets good for them California state
Senator Scott weiner has proposed a bill
that would require vehicles from not
going more than 10 mph above the speed
limit most State already have that it's
called a
wife oh sexist
people in Chicago 47 migrants were
arrested for retail theft and burglary
well at least they're
assimilating Dunkin Donuts is being sued
by 10 plaintiffs who are lactose
intolerant for being charged extra for
non-dairy milk when reached for Comet
the CEO of Duncan replied they can blow
it out their
ass Michigan Governor Gretchen Whitmer
was mocked for appearing in a sketch
with a giant potato to pitch taxpayer
funded Community College hey that was
some of my best work said one
[Laughter]
man
oh man Democratic Congressman Jamal
Bowman has proposed a $4 trillion
reparations plan he hasn't worked out
the details yet he just wants to sound
the
[Music]
alarm I feel dirty I feel dirty
transgender golfer Haley Davidson is
pushing back against critics of her wins
on the women's Pro Tour claiming any
strength Advantage is negated by the
extra time she spends at the ball
washing
[Laughter]
machine now that's good
little
terrible the uh San Antonio Zoo is
offering hippo poop scented candles for
Valentine's Day I put a lot of work into
those candles said one
[Laughter]
hippo terrible terrible people how dare
you clap
Applebees has introduced a subscription
plan that allows couples to have 52 date
nights for only
$200 that works out to $4 per meal spent
regretting the man you
married an American Airlines flight was
forced to turn around after one of the
passengers farted
excessively but I say why turn around
that would have been the perfect flight
for the rest of us to get away with
farting interesting yeah it is
interesting very interesting and finally
earlier this week the double Big Mac
returned to McDonald's in related news
so did Chris
Christie
now to the
news this is bad Republican gov show
Texas some love yep 25 Republican
Governor signed a letter of support
fully backing Texas in its fight against
the federal government to protect the
southern border as the feds got the
green light to take down razor wire
meant to secure it and to show support
for the Lone Star State they signed the
letter using barbecue
sauce quote we stand in solidarity with
our fellow Governor Greg Abbott in
utilizing every tool and strategy
inclusing razor wire fences stand in
solidarity poor choice of words don't
you think they should have said let's
Roll I love
him I love
him but they rightly point out the Biden
Administration has left America quote
completely vulnerable to Illegal
immigration and that Texas has every
legal justification to protect its
sovereignty so 25 GOP goves support
Texas and predictably not a single
Democrat gov signed the statement
perhaps they were tooo busy trying to
find shelter for thousands of illegal
immigrants or perhaps to steal a word
from the illegals they lack the
coones but independent presidential
hopeful JFK Jr lended support for Texas
saying Biden's failure leaves States no
choice but to take matters into their
own hands and a country Without Borders
is not a country at all so what's next a
civil war with Democrat versus
Republican states millions could die die
specifically the ones in Democrat States
who will be stuck defending themselves
with men's tampons and preferred
[Music]
pronouns please don't shoot I'm a
they fact is if Biden decides to attack
the Alamo he'd still manage to lose even
though it's a
museum so my money's on the GOP they
know how to chug beer fire guns and make
sweet love to the music of Lee Greenwood
while Dems are only able to kill the
American dream late night comedy and
innocent crew members on a film
set but all kidding aside there is one
upside to a Civil War at least this time
when the Army leaves billions of dollars
of equipment behind it will be in
America a thoughtful provoking way to
end that comment cat cat what would you
do if you were president and I know
that's a fantasy since you are a
female okay um less yes I would simply
do less right uh such as not interfere
with State's rights and that kind of
thing I'm okay I know it's so unlike me
to be cynical but uh I can't help but
notice this is a letter of Republican
Governors which doesn't actually like do
anything mhm um Republicans or anybody
in congress actually it could be as
simple as if they didn't want Biden to
do this they could just not fund it
Congress so little actually so so rarely
does anything we forget that they do
have the power of the purse they can
simply say there's that's how it's
supposed to be set up no we're not going
to fund that so it's not going to happen
but we don't we don't see anybody really
moving to do that so don't fund the feds
if they wanted to on any issue Congress
can move to not fund the feds on
something unless of course they just
rather complain about it I just learned
something here and I've quickly
forgotten
it what do you say tan do you think that
there's a possibility of a Civil War and
if so are you looking forward to it
that's why you booked me isn't it yeah
yeah the accent are you still are you
still in your
militia I mean you're wearing a
sleeveless shirt all that's missing
there they're militias per state and
region of State where do you want to
start on the Civil War we can go back to
the Tariff of Abominations you know it
took years to get to the Civil War um I
have a deep personal admiration for
governor Abbott and all the people who
are standing with him because when
somebody comes knocking at my door when
I'm blasting my Almond Brothers and
tells me too loud too loud I
say what are you going to do about it
you're going to come in and make me stop
and that's essentially what he is saying
to Joe Biden and it's so astonishing
that Biden is sad band of Desperados you
talk about all the Democrats that he
Biden has openly violated the laws of
this country and when someone tries to
enforce them they're like no no no no no
we need more death destruction societal
and financial hardship we want people
pouring across the border so the only
way to stop it at this point is for
Biden to uh militarize the National
Guard and and go in and sees the Border
do you think he's stupid and dangerous
enough to do that so again it's the what
are you going to do yes so again it's
what are you going to do come in and
stop me yeah exactly it's like a an
amplified version of an episode of cops
you know the cops show up knock on the
door yeah Dean's playing the Almond
Brothers I feel bad for the people
getting arrested on that show I do too I
always sympathize with the guy without
the shirt on trying just smoking a
little crack yeah yeah ow ow ow Doug
welcome to the show I'm glad you wore
pants yeah
happen I didn't shave my legs today
that's why yes I was looking forward to
seeing your legs but um what do you make
of this I mean Joe has gone from like
calling half of America worthless to now
maybe contemplating going into a state
listen if he's not going to take care of
the border right then the the Texas guy
you know Abbot he's got to take care of
himself it's basically uh razor wire
versus uh wire cutters it's basically
the law and whoever's got more the guy's
got more razor wire for that thing or
they can cut it out and I got to tell
you if the government wins
this Abbott's going to be defenseless
yeah it's not going
to ah I thought about that I stumbled on
it but no I got it it took me a while
defenseless that's you know that is a
great title for like an coulter's next
book like it's like the or or a
conservatives book and it's about the
border and it's defenseless and somebody
that cover like this oh always yeah
that's like this is the like Universal
post for I'm about ready to say some
reactionary speaking of Julie oh God
yeah where does this all end is there
going to be some kind of resolution or
do you think we're on the verge of Civil
War isn't this happening at an amazing
time 20124 is kicking off yeah this is a
really bad time for Biden because he has
screwed up so badly at the border and
these Governors more power to him even
though they have no power um you know it
it is their us constitutional right the
state of Texas to defend itself
obviously this Administration isn't
doing jack about it um I think that they
should go a step further I thought the
wall that Trump wanted to build was a
bit unrealistic I mean there's imminent
domain you can't possibly build a wall
across the entire border um these barb
wire wire fences I think are weak I
think they should go with like an
electric fence I hear those work well
like to contain the dogs in your yard so
you keep them out I also think they
should hand out as like welcome gifts
like those ball washing machines that
you showed earlier well we are giving
free sex changes yes so why not give the
ball washing machine with the sex change
that sounds like a great idea swag bag
if you will swag do you need collars
with the this issue alone I honestly do
believe is what is going to lose the
election for for Biden I he was supposed
to assign his VP to figure out the
crisis the root of this and she hasn't
done a darn thing is he going to pick a
new VP because she sucks I think they're
going to have to replace both of them
yeah but I'm just saying if he's going
to run all right she's not going to help
him
again we must move on to the next block
which means there is a break up next
would a world without journalists be bad
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else